From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
I used to be really scared of roller coasters. I didn't like them at all. If I just looked at them, I'd start to feel upset and kind of sick.
我以前真的很怕坐过山车。我一点也不喜欢。光是看着它们，我就会感到心烦意乱，甚至有点想吐。
Tess is 12, and back when she was 10, she and her dad were driving by Six Flags Magic Mountain. And she told her dad that when kids at school talked about going on roller coasters, and which ones they'd ridden, and how awesome they are, she always felt kind of dumb because she was so scared of them.
苔丝今年12岁。在她10岁那年，她和爸爸开车经过六旗魔术山乐园。她告诉爸爸，当学校里的孩子们谈论坐过山车、讨论他们坐过哪些以及过山车有多刺激时，她总觉得自己很笨，因为她太怕坐过山车了。
My dad was like, let's go there sometime so you can conquer your fear. At first, I thought he was joking, or he was crazy, or something.
我爸当时说，找个时间带我去那里，让我去克服恐惧。起初，我还以为他在开玩笑，或者他疯了什么的。
He wasn't, of course. And he made this recording of the trip that I heard on this podcast called Unfictional that I want to play you some of now, because this recording is great. Her dad is Bob Carson, who hosts that show, Unfictional.
当然，他不是在开玩笑。他录下了那次旅行的过程，我在一个叫《非虚构》的播客节目中听到了这段录音。我想现在放给你们听听，因为这段录音太棒了。她的爸爸是鲍勃·卡森，也就是《非虚构》节目的主持人。
Magic Mountain Parkway! Wait, is that something we're going on?
魔术山大道！等等，那是我们要去玩的东西吗？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑声]
I don't know. I don't know what that one is.
我不知道。我不知道那是什么。
That better not be something we're going on.
最好别是我们要去玩的东西。
So they get to the park, and they start with the easy roller coasters, right? They'd watched videos of the ones they would go on to prepare. And so after they do the Road Runner Express, and the Gold Rusher, they advance to the Ninja, which turns you sideways. And then they came to the big challenge.
他们到达乐园后，先从简单的过山车开始，对吧？他们提前看了要玩的过山车的视频做准备。在玩完“走鹃快车”和“淘金者”之后，他们接着挑战了“忍者”过山车，那个会让你横向翻转。然后，他们遇到了大挑战。
All right, next stop, Revolution, Tess's first looping roller coaster.
好了，下一站，革命过山车，苔丝人生中第一个带环路的过山车。
So they approach this huge, frightening-looking steel contraption. Can I just say, looping is a fantastically bland way to describe what this thing does. It is an enormous loop, nine stories high, like a giant Hot Wheels loop that flips you totally upside down. Anyway, here's the recording of what happened.
于是他们走近了这个看起来巨大且恐怖的钢铁装置。恕我直言，用“环路”来描述这个东西的运行方式实在太平淡了。这是一个巨大的环，有九层楼高，就像一个巨大的风火轮轨道，能把你彻底倒挂过来。不管怎样，这是当时发生的事情的录音。
[CREAKING]
[吱呀声]
Are you a little nervous now?
你现在有点紧张吗？
Yeah, a little.
嗯，有一点。
Relax, relax.
放松，放松。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Here comes the loop!
环路来了！
Here we go.
我们走吧。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
I just went through a loop! I just went through a loop! And it wasn't even that bad!
我刚刚穿过了一个环路！我刚刚穿过了一个环路！而且根本没那么糟！
OK, what just happened, Tess?
好了，刚刚发生了什么，苔丝？
I just rode a looping roller coaster for the first time in my life. And it was so exciting, and it wasn't even that bad. I am a different person than I was a minute ago.
我人生中第一次坐了环路过山车。太刺激了，而且根本没那么糟。现在的我和一分钟前的我完全是两个人。
Ladies and gentlemen, when does it ever happen like this, right? That you change so fast? You were one thing, now you're another. Change usually takes time. Psyching yourself up, and self-help books, and advice from friends, and one tentative step after the next. This is about as efficient as it ever gets.
女士们先生们，这种事怎么可能发生得这么快，对吧？你原本是那样，现在却变成了另一个人。改变通常需要时间。给自己打气、看自助书籍、听朋友建议、一步一步试探性地前行。这已经是最高效的改变方式了。
I am a different person than I was a minute ago.
现在的我和一分钟前的我完全是两个人。
Today on our show, it's the new year. People are making resolutions. We have stories of people deciding they are going to totally transform themselves, overcome their fears, finally change the things about themselves that have dogged them and held them back their entire lives, things that, in some cases, it's hard to believe could ever change. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是新年。人们都在制定新年计划。我们要讲的故事关于一些人决定彻底改变自我、克服恐惧、最终改掉那些困扰并束缚他们一生的性格弱点，在某些情况下，这些弱点甚至让人觉得根本不可能改变。请继续收听。
My grandma Vicki is 90 years old. She lives in a nursing home, and lately she can't stop talking about her new boyfriend, Frank. They're very much in love, and their dialogue is straight out of a romantic comedy. I mean, this is what it sounds like when they're drinking tea.
我奶奶维琪今年90岁。她住在养老院，最近她总是不停地提起她的新男朋友弗兰克。他们坠入了爱河，他们的对话简直就像浪漫喜剧里的台词。我是说，这就是他们喝茶时的样子。
Have enough sugar?
糖够了吗？
Not as sweet as you.
没有你甜。
You are one of a kind, you are.
你是独一无二的，真是这样。
I also told you they broke the mold.
我也跟你说过，你就是那种上帝造完就毁掉模具的人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's the way Frank talks. He's like an encyclopedia of love cliches, but totally sincere about it.
弗兰克就是这样说话的。他简直就是一本爱情陈词滥调的百科全书，但他说的时候却无比真诚。
What do you want to do, hon?
亲爱的，你想做什么？
Stay close to you, gorgeous. I've been in love before, but never like this.
待在你身边，美丽的。我以前也谈过恋爱，但从未像现在这样。
Yes. That's how I go to sleep at night, with those words in my ear.
是的。我晚上就是枕着这些话入眠的。
Again, Grandma is 90. Frank's 62, which makes him 28 years younger than my grandma. That's not even a cougar. That's a different animal. It's like a water buffalo. Also, she's partially deaf, while Frank is blind, he's got one leg, and it's an interracial relationship. As a stand up comedian, I've never felt more pressure to write a joke.
再说一次，奶奶90岁了。弗兰克62岁，比我奶奶小28岁。这甚至都不算“美洲狮”（老牛吃嫩草），这是另一种生物了。就像水牛一样。此外，奶奶半聋，而弗兰克双目失明，他还少了一条腿，而且这是一段跨种族恋情。作为一个脱口秀演员，我从未感到有这么大的压力去写一个段子。
This is in no way the grandma who raised me. She's not a lovestruck, soft hearted kind of girl. She's a tough Italian lady from New Jersey, right out of central casting. If you've ever seen a mob movie in the last 30 years, you got the picture. Her eyebrows are drawn on, but not at the appropriate height, so she always looks shocked. It's all there, the opinions, the accent, and yes, even the racism.
这根本不是我从小认识的那个奶奶。她不是那种坠入爱河、心肠柔软的女孩。她是那种来自新泽西的硬派意大利老太太，简直像是从选角导演那里直接走出来的一样。如果你在过去30年里看过黑帮电影，你就能想象出她的样子。她的眉毛是画上去的，但高度不对，所以她看起来总是很震惊。这一切都在她身上，那些观点、口音，还有，是的，甚至包括种族偏见。
So a relationship with a blind, one legged black guy, not the thing you'd expect from grandma. And yet, none of that's the most surprising part. What's most surprising is that she has anything to do with a man at all. The grandma I've always known, she despised men. Like, she was fundamentally against them as a concept. So all this lovey dovey Frank business, it's like she's been inhabited by an alien.
所以，和一个盲人、缺腿的黑人谈恋爱，这实在不是你会从奶奶身上预料到的事。然而，这些都不是最令人惊讶的部分。最令人惊讶的是，她竟然会和男人有任何往来。我一直认识的那个奶奶，她鄙视男人。就像从本质上反对男人这个概念一样。所以，所有这些和弗兰克亲亲我我的事，简直就像是被外星人附身了一样。
In order to understand how opposed my grandma was to men, I need to tell you the very weird story of the tenant who lived with my family when I was growing up. This was in Bloomfield, New Jersey. My dad died in a car crash when I was a baby, so my mom and I moved in with my aunt, grandma, and great grandma. We lived in a two story house with a basement. Each floor had a different set of women.
为了理解奶奶对男人的反感到了什么程度，我得告诉你们那个住在我家里的房客的奇怪故事，那是在我成长过程中发生的。地点在新泽西州的布卢姆菲尔德。我爸在我婴儿时死于车祸，所以我和妈妈搬去跟姑姑、奶奶和曾祖母住在一起。我们住在一栋带地下室的两层楼房里。每层楼住着不同的人。
The only other guy in the house besides me was our tenant, John. He rented out our living room. John was always there, lying on the rug, shirtless, in black sweatpants, eating waffles, and watching animal shows.
家里除了我之外，唯一的男人就是我们的房客约翰。他租了我们的客厅。约翰总是待在那里，光着膀子躺在地毯上，穿着黑色运动裤，吃着华夫饼，看动物节目。
My grandma didn't like John. She treated him like a second class citizen. Whenever she walked through the living room, she'd look at him and grunt. She was fixated on keeping him away from all our food.
奶奶不喜欢约翰。她把他当作二等公民对待。每当她穿过客厅，她都会看他一眼然后嘟囔几句。她特别执着于不让他碰我们所有的食物。
I'd open the fridge and there'd be stickers on everything there. Milk, cold cuts, leftover pasta. They all said "Not for John." Then one day I thought I overheard my aunt saying John and Grandma Vicki were married. And I'm like, what?
我打开冰箱，每样东西上都有贴纸。牛奶、冷盘、剩下的意面。上面都写着“不许给约翰”。然后有一天，我好像无意中听到姑姑说约翰和维琪奶奶是夫妻。我就想，什么？
And you said to me "John is married to Grandma Vicki? That's her husband?"
你当时对我说：“约翰是维琪奶奶的丈夫？那是她丈夫？”
That's my mom.
那是我的妈妈。
I was like, "Yeah, who did you think he was?" You actually didn't know that they were married.
我说：“是啊，你以为他是谁？”你当时竟然不知道他们是夫妻。
No, I didn't know that we're married. You know why? Because nobody told me.
不，我不知道他们是夫妻。你知道为什么吗？因为没人告诉我。
Why did you tell me he was the tenant?
那你为什么告诉我他是房客？
I only said it maybe one time. Because that was a joke to us. They weren't a happy couple any longer. But I didn't realize that you gave it a category in your head like that.
我可能只说过一次。因为那对我们来说是个笑话。他们早就不再是一对幸福的夫妻了。但我没意识到你脑子里把它归为了那一类。
Nobody ever--
没人曾经——
I was shocked when you said that to me, because how could you not figure that out? He was our father.
你说那话的时候我很震惊，因为你怎么会没发现呢？他可是我们的父亲。
Because he lived in the living room and nobody ever called him, this is my father, or this is my grandfather. No one ever said that.
因为他住在客厅里，从来没有人叫他“这是我爸爸”或者“这是我爷爷”。从来没有人这么说过。
But it didn't hurt you.
但那并没有伤害到你。
No, it didn't hurt me, but that is weird to just one day be like, oh, the tenant is my grandfather.
不，没伤害到我，但有一天突然发现房客是我爷爷，这真的很奇怪。
Since you put it that way.
既然你这么说的话。
So how many years just about was he living there before, you know, he eventually gets kicked out or whatever?
那么他在被赶走或者怎么样之前，大概在家里住了多少年？
I don't know.
我不知道。
OK.
好吧。
It's too far back.
时间太久了。
Right.
对。
And plus, when I don't like something, I block it out. So I can remember some of it, but if I don't want to remember it, it's gone. It goes.
而且，我不喜欢的东西，我会把它屏蔽掉。所以我记得一部分，但如果我不想记得，它就消失了。它走了。
OK, OK. But how long, just approximate from when he moves into the living room till he gets out of the house?
好吧，好吧。但大概从他搬进客厅到他离开家，大概过了多久？
15 years.
15年。
About 15 years?
大约15年？
Yeah, mhm.
是啊，嗯。
That is insane. 15 years he lived in the living room?
这太疯狂了。他在客厅住了15年？
It was bizarre.
这真的很离奇。
Yeah.
是啊。
I'm 33 now, and two and a half decades have passed since I learned that John was my grandpa. And you know what? This conversation that you're hearing right now, this is the first time my mom and I have ever talked about it since that day when I was eight.
我现在33岁了，距离我得知约翰是我爷爷已经过去了二十五年。你知道吗？你们现在听到的这段谈话，是我和我妈妈自那次我八岁那年之后第一次谈论这件事。
There were so many lies happening in the house at one time, do you know what I mean? Because nobody was just saying what was going on. It was like a corrupt government or something. I don't even know.
家里当时发生了太多谎言，你懂我的意思吗？因为没人说出真相。就像一个腐败的政府之类的。我甚至不知道。
It seemed normal to us. Whatever the situation is, you want to make it seem as normal as can be.
对我们来说这似乎很正常。不管情况如何，你都想让它看起来尽可能正常。
Think about that for a second, what that says about my family's aggressive lack of interest in processing feelings. So being a DeVito, I learned John was my grandpa, and then I didn't change anything about my behavior at all towards him. And he didn't act any different with me either. He stayed the tenant.
想想看，这说明我家人对处理情感有着多么强烈的缺乏兴趣。所以作为一个德维托家族的人，我得知约翰是我爷爷后，我对他没有任何行为上的改变。他对我也没有任何不同。他依然是那个房客。
Here's how my grandpa ended up in the doghouse. One day, years before I was born, Grandma goes out to move Grandpa's car in the driveway. She pulls down the sun visor.
这是我爷爷怎么会被“打入冷宫”的原因。多年前，在我出生之前，有一天奶奶出去移爷爷的车。她拉下遮阳板。
And all these on the envelopes fell on me. I said, what the heck? These are apartments that he rented that he-- I don't want to really go into this crap. Not now, and I don't want to remember. I really don't.
所有的信封都掉到了我身上。我说，这到底是什么鬼？这些是他租的公寓，他……我不想再提这些烂事了。现在不想，我也不想回忆。真的不想。
I got you.
我明白了。
My mom filled me in on the details my grandma couldn't bring herself to say. The envelopes contained pictures of Grandpa with another woman-- the one he was renting secret apartments for. For Grandma, the marriage was over. But Grandpa John refused to move out, because he always denied ever having an affair. And Grandma never filed for divorce because she didn't have the money to move herself and four kids. There was a total standoff in the house.
我妈妈告诉我奶奶无法说出口的细节。信封里装着爷爷和另一个女人的照片——就是那个他偷偷为之租下公寓的女人。对奶奶来说，婚姻结束了。但爷爷约翰拒绝搬走，因为他一直否认有外遇。而奶奶从来没申请离婚，因为她没有钱供自己和四个孩子搬出去。家里陷入了彻底的僵局。
So then he took upon himself to sleep on the floor in the living room, because he never was going to sleep in my bedroom.
所以他就自作主张睡在客厅的地板上，因为他永远没法睡进我的卧室。
Right. Didn't he ever want to get back together or try to win you back in any way?
对。他有没有想过复合或者试图用什么方式挽回你？
No. No, I don't think so. Because I know he thought it was hopeless. Because what he did was more than I can ever understand.
不。不，我不这么认为。因为我知道他觉得没希望了。因为他做的事是我永远无法理解的。
So did you guys establish any ground rules between the two of you, places he was allowed to go? Did you talk at all? Because you were in the same house.
那么你们俩之间有没有建立过任何基本准则？比如他可以去的地方？你们交流过吗？因为你们住在同一个屋檐下。
No, never.
不，从来没有。
No?
没有？
No, never. He only came in late at night. Then he'd be gone in the morning. So we didn't connect. No.
不，从来没有。他只有深夜才回来。然后早上就走了。所以我们没有交集。没有。
I remember all the food in the fridge was marked "Not for John."
我记得冰箱里所有的食物都贴着“不许给约翰”。
Yeah. Well, yeah, because I felt I wasn't going to pay to feed the bum.
是啊。嗯，是啊，因为我觉得我没理由花钱养那个流浪汉。
Would you just in your head just pretend he wasn't there?
你会在脑子里假装他不存在吗？
You have to. What are you going to do? He's not worth me going to the crazy house for, no way. No way.
你必须这么做。你还能怎么办？他不值得我为了他而精神崩溃，绝不可能。不可能的。
They hadn't always been unhappy. She says he was this charming, funny guy who loved to dance and bought her beautiful gifts, rings, necklaces, a blue fox fur coat. They had four daughters together, big family dinners every night, vacations at the Jersey Shore. It was nice.
他们并不总是过得不幸福。她说他曾经是一个充满魅力、风趣幽默的人，喜欢跳舞，还给她买漂亮的礼物，戒指、项链，一件蓝色的狐狸毛皮大衣。他们有四个女儿，每天晚上都有盛大的家庭晚餐，在泽西海岸度假。那时候很美好。
But now she ignored him. She chose not to recognize her husband sleeping under the same roof. She never explained to my mom or sisters why their dad had moved into the living room. So sometimes they'd sneak him a plate of food or give him some extra money.
但现在她无视他。她选择不去承认她丈夫睡在同一个屋檐下。她从不向我妈妈和阿姨们解释她们的爸爸为什么搬到了客厅。所以有时她们会偷偷送他一盘食物或给他点额外的钱。
Finally, when I was in seventh grade, they forced him out. My aunts and great grandma were fed up he wasn't helping with the mortgage. I never saw him again. And soon after, he died of a heart attack. When my grandma heard the news, she was blank, absolutely no emotion. He'd already been dead to her for years.
终于，在我上七年级的时候，她们强迫他搬走了。姑姑们和曾祖母受够了他不分担房贷。我再也没见过他。不久之后，他死于心脏病。奶奶听到消息时，面无表情，绝对没有任何情绪波动。多年来，他在她心中早已死了。
There were some other guys who tried with Grandma. I mean, really tried. Seriously courted her.
还有其他男人试图追求过奶奶。我是说，真的尝试过。非常认真地追求过她。
First, there was Mr. Bill, our fix it man. He'd always try to kiss her, and she'd wiggle out of there. Then there was Gene, a school crossing guard. He wanted to marry her, and proclaimed his love over and over.
首先是比尔先生，我们的修理工。他总是试图亲吻她，而她会扭动身子躲开。然后是吉恩，一个学校的交通督导员。他想娶她，一遍又一遍地宣告他的爱。
And her? There's no other way to say it. She took huge pleasure in turning them down. It was the one activity that gave her pure joy.
而她呢？只能说，她拒绝他们时感到极大的快感。那是唯一能给她带来纯粹快乐的活动。
It was hard to watch. I was in high school then, and I feel bad for Gene. I wanted to pull him aside and be like, dude, just walk away. You're a crossing guard. You of all people should know when to stop. I remember he used to leave these sobbing voicemails, private outpourings of emotion. And Grandma would play them for me, laughing while she cleaned the kitchen.
这很难看。那时我还在上高中，我为吉恩感到难过。我当时想把他拉到一边说，兄弟，走开吧。你只是个交通督导员。你们所有人都应该知道什么时候该停手。我记得他过去常留下那些痛哭流涕的语音留言，倾诉着内心的情感。而奶奶会放给我听，一边打扫厨房一边大笑。
Gene would call up crying.
吉恩哭着打来电话。
Oh yeah.
哦，是啊。
Do you remember that? "Vicki, I love you. Vicki, I miss you. Vicki, I want to marry you."
你还记得吗？“维琪，我爱你。维琪，我想你。维琪，我想娶你。”
That's enough. Oh, he was unbelievable. I didn't need that.
够了。哦，他简直不可思议。我才不需要那个。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't need you in my life. That's the way I felt.
我不需要你在我生命中出现。这就是我的感受。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't need this commotion in my life.
我不需要生活中有这种骚动。
Yeah, that makes sense. I always took it as, I don't know, I guess you were more guarded, or they were paying for what Grandpa did. Do you know what I mean? Whereas, he wronged you, he cheated on you, he hurt you so bad that you wouldn't open up to them because of that. Is that accurate at all or no?
是啊，这说得通。我一直以为，我不知道，我猜你是更自我保护，或者他们是在替爷爷所做的事买单。你懂我的意思吗？他亏待了你，他欺骗了你，他伤害你那么深，以至于你因为那件事而拒绝向他们敞开心扉。这准确吗？还是不是？
I lost a lot of trust in men, huh? Yeah.
我失去了对男人的很多信任，对吧？是啊。
So when my mom walked into the nursing home one day and she saw this guy pulled up next to my grandma in his wheelchair, needless to say, she was surprised.
所以当我妈妈有一天走进养老院，看到这个男人坐在轮椅上靠在奶奶身边，不用说，她很惊讶。
And she introduced me to Frank to say that's her boyfriend, and they found one another. How nice that they found one another in this place.
她把我介绍给弗兰克，说这是她男朋友，他们找到了彼此。在这个地方找到彼此，真是太好了。
Right.
对。
And I'm like, huh. I thought I was hearing things. So I said, how nice. Nice to meet you. I didn't know what to say. I just tried to hide my surprise because I was startled, wondering what frame of mind she was in.
我心想，嗯？我以为我听错了。所以我说，太好了。很高兴见到你。我不知道该说什么。我只是试图隐藏我的惊讶，因为我被吓到了，想知道她现在的精神状态如何。
My mom wondered if she messed up her medication. No, really. She worried about that. We all did. Since then, it's been an adjustment, the thought that Grandma could ever have feelings for a man.
我妈妈担心她是不是搞错了药物。不，说真的。她为此担心。我们都担心。从那以后，这成了一种调整，奶奶竟然会对一个男人产生感情。
My grandma moved into the nursing home for health reasons a year ago, and it was brutal, the way those things often are. She'd been living with my mom and my aunt. Their life at home was so close, everyone sitting around the table, up in each other's business in a good way, every day. There were always multiple conversations happening at the same time. You jump in and out of them like double Dutch.
奶奶因为健康原因在一年前搬进了养老院，这很残酷，就像这类事情通常发生的那样。她以前一直和我妈妈及阿姨住在一起。她们在家里的生活是如此亲密，每个人坐在桌旁，大家每天都在关心对方的事，这种感觉很好。总是有多场对话同时进行。你像跳双荷兰式跳绳一样跳进跳出这些对话。
And Grandma was the center of it all. She held court. Her laugh would fill the room. Now she was alone, and she hated it. She didn't talk to anyone, wouldn't leave her room for months. Every time we visited her, she begged for us to take her home. That is, until she met Frank.
而奶奶是这一切的中心。她主导一切。她的笑声会填满整个房间。现在她独自一人，她讨厌这样。她不跟任何人说话，几个月都不走出房间。每次我们去看她，她都恳求我们带她回家。直到，她遇到了弗兰克。
Frank was walking toward me, and he said hello. And he says, "What's your name? I'm Frank." And I told him my name. Then I find out this guy is blind, totally blind. I felt very bad. And I told him if there's anything that you need or you want me to-- just don't hesitate. Let me know.
弗兰克朝我走来，向我打招呼。他说：“你叫什么名字？我是弗兰克。”我告诉了他我的名字。后来我才知道这个男人是盲人，完全失明。我觉得很难过。我告诉他，如果有什么需要或者你想让我做的……不用犹豫。随时告诉我。
And I asked her not to let me fall.
而我请求她不要让我跌倒。
My grandma had wheeled up to him and held out her right arm. Frank had lost his leg and was struggling to make it down the hallway. That day, he was wearing a prosthetic leg and using a cane.
奶奶推着轮椅靠近他，伸出她的右臂。弗兰克失去了一条腿，正在挣扎着走过走廊。那天，他戴着假肢，拿着手杖。
Your grandmother would hold me on one side. She said, I won't let you fall. She said she's going to be my eyes.
你奶奶会扶着我的一边。她说，我不会让你跌倒。她说她要做我的眼睛。
After that, my grandma always sat next to Frank in the cafeteria.
从那以后，奶奶总是坐在弗兰克旁边的餐厅里。
She used to take charge. She would tell me my juice is here. Whatever I'm getting ready consume is here, on my left, on my right.
她习惯于掌控局面。她会告诉我果汁在这里。无论我准备吃什么，都在这里，在我的左边，或者我的右边。
I see them do this all the time.
我经常看到他们这样做。
Wait, hon. I'm going to turn the dish around so that you can eat the fish, because the fish is in front of you, and the fish is very good. Over that way. That's it. OK?
等等，亲爱的。我要把盘子转过来让你吃鱼，因为鱼在你面前，鱼很好吃。往那边一点。就这样。好吗？
As long as I can find my mouth I'm all right. I get a lot of help from you.
只要我能找到我的嘴，我就没事。你帮了我很多忙。
They're like a couple of cozy cellmates, playing cards, watching Family Feud. Frank can't see anything, so Grandma gives him the play by play. They talk about what life was like on the outside. She loved a beer at the end of a long day. For Frank, it was rum and Coke.
他们就像一对舒适的狱友，玩牌，看电视节目《家庭问答》。弗兰克什么都看不见，所以奶奶会为他现场解说。他们谈论外面的生活是什么样的。她喜欢在一天的尽头喝杯啤酒。对弗兰克来说，那是朗姆酒兑可乐。
Frank told my grandma he used to work at a factory, wrapping products and plastic. And like her, he was married and had his heart broken. He said his wife fell in love and left him for another man. Then he lost his eyesight to macular degeneration, then his leg to blood clots.
弗兰克告诉奶奶他过去在工厂工作，用塑料包装产品。和她一样，他也结过婚，心碎过。他说他妻子爱上了别人，离开了他。然后他因黄斑变性失去了视力，又因血栓失去了腿。
And now he lives in this place. It's not the Ritz. As soon as you get off the elevators, there's just ambient screaming, a full chorus of wails and moans.
现在他住在这里。这又不是里兹酒店。你一出电梯，就能听到环境中的尖叫声，那是哀嚎和呻吟的合唱。
There's a smell of sickness which attaches itself to everything. It's a real playground for all five senses. But somehow, Grandma and Frank together make it all a little more tolerable.
这里有一种依附在一切事物上的病态气息。这简直是五官的游乐场。但不知何故，奶奶和弗兰克在一起让这一切变得更加可以忍受。
[SHOUTING]
[喊叫声]
Good Lord.
上帝啊。
No matter how much goes on, you never get used to that, right?
无论发生多少事，你永远不会习惯这一点，对吧？
Another day in paradise.
天堂里的又一天。
[SHOUTING]
[喊叫声]
You know that feeling when you hang out with someone a lot and you just want to be with them all the time, like going home at the end of the day feels like a tiny loss? That happened to Grandma and Frank. It was just they had to go to their separate rooms.
你知道那种感觉吗？当你和某人经常待在一起，你只想一直和他们在一起，就像一天结束时回家感觉是一种小小的损失？这种情况发生在奶奶和弗兰克身上。只是他们必须回到各自的房间。
I would realize how much I miss her, and I said to myself, something's going on here. Soon as I wake up, I'd been looking to hear her voice first. And I told her. I said, I never missed anyone the way I miss you when we're apart. So I must be falling for you. And evidently, you for me. I tell her, you can go ahead and admit it.
我会意识到我是多么想念她，我就对自己说，这里面有点什么。每天一醒来，我就想先听到她的声音。我告诉她。我说，当我们在分开的时候，我从来没有像想你这样想念任何人。所以我一定爱上你了。显然，你也爱上我了。我告诉她，你可以承认了。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Because she knew I was right, and I knew I was right. So I told her, I love her, and she told me she loved me back. I said, ah-hah.
因为她知道我是对的，我也知道我是对的。所以我告诉她，我爱她，她也告诉我她也爱我。我说，啊哈。
It slipped out.
这不小心说漏了嘴。
He's beautiful. And a lady my age being-- you know, that's magical. Lord.
他很帅。而且到了我这个年纪还能——你知道，这太神奇了。老天。
What about the first kiss? Tell me about that.
那初吻呢？告诉我那件事。
It wasn't bad.
还不赖。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That was a toot. I was surprised.
那太搞笑了。我很惊讶。
I mean, you have to be more surprised than anybody by this.
我是说，你应该比任何人都对这件事感到惊讶。
Yeah, but I think it's beautiful. I really do. I really do.
是啊，但我认为这很美。真的，我真的是这么认为。
When it comes to Frank, I want to please him. I want to make him happy. Frank, he's special. And then for two people to be so happy and good with one another, to be finding pleasure and comfort in a place like this, I find a certain contentment being with Frank all the time.
说到弗兰克，我想让他开心。我想让他幸福。弗兰克，他是特别的。对于两个人来说，能够如此快乐地相处，在这样一个地方找到快乐和安慰，我觉得和弗兰克在一起有一种满足感。
I kept asking her to explain this huge transformation, but it's pretty simple, actually. She's 90 years old. She lives in a nursing home, and she fell in love. Recently, Frank asked my grandma to marry him. She said yes.
我一直在问她解释这种巨大的转变，但其实很简单。她90岁了。她住在养老院，她坠入了爱河。最近，弗兰克向我奶奶求婚了。她答应了。
Anthony DeVito is a comedian in New York. His website, anthonydevitocomedy.com
安东尼·德维托是纽约的一名喜剧演员。他的网站是anthonydevitocomedy.com。
[MUSIC - "LOVE REALLY CHANGED ME" BY SPOOKY TOOTH]
[音乐 - 《爱情真的改变了我》 by Spooky Tooth]
This is my first time. I have never, ever used this bus pass and the bus system. I heard it's terrible. Let me see. I think we have to cross.
这是我第一次。我从来、从来没用过这张公交卡和这个公交系统。我听说它很糟糕。让我看看。我想我们得过马路。
One Monday, she rode a bus as the next of those many steps that she has to do to become an American. This was a year ago. Today's show is a rerun.
一个周一，她搭乘了公交车，这是她成为美国人所必须经历的众多步骤之一。那是一年前的事了。今天的节目是重播。
This woman is from Afghanistan, but she lives in Detroit now. There are currently a record number of people-- over 60 million, according to the United Nations-- displaced by violence and persecution and needing to start all over elsewhere, change their lives, transform themselves. M is one of them.
这位女士来自阿富汗，但她现在住在底特律。目前，据联合国统计，全球有超过6000万人因暴力和迫害流离失所，需要从头开始在其他地方建立生活，改变自己，实现转变。M就是其中之一。
She's right now living in a temporary home for asylum seekers called Freedom House. And at Freedom House, they've taught her how to put together an American style resume and go to the doctor in America. Today's lesson is how to get around the city independently. This turns out to be one of the most critical skills if you're going to get a job or really do much of anything in this country, right?
她目前住在一家为寻求庇护者提供的临时住所——自由之家。在自由之家，他们教她如何撰写美式简历，如何在医疗机构看病。今天的课程是如何独立在这个城市出行。如果你想找工作或者在这个国家做任何事情，这竟然是最关键的技能之一，对吧？
And the Detroit buses are chronically late and confusing. And in the past, other Freedom House refugees have gotten lost for hours when they've been sent out on their very first bus ride. One of them circled around and around and around on the route, not getting off, until finally the driver asked where the guy was going and then drove the bus to Freedom House, which is actually a couple blocks away from the route, to drop the guy off.
而且底特律的公交车经常晚点，还让人困惑。过去，其他自由之家的难民在第一次乘公交车时迷路过好几个小时。其中一个人在路线上绕了又绕，就是不下车，直到司机问那人要去哪里，然后直接把车开到离路线只有几个街区远的自由之家，把他放下。
Since then, to minimize mishaps, usually a volunteer goes with. And, because I wanted to record this, Freedom House decided not to send a volunteer. They informed me when I arrived, basically, I would be the volunteer.
从那以后，为了减少差错，通常会有志愿者陪同。而且，因为我想录下这个过程，自由之家决定不派志愿者。当我到达时，他们通知我，基本上，我就是那个志愿者。
I have you with me, so I'm not afraid that I will be lost.
你有陪着我，所以我不怕我会迷路。
Unfortunately for both of us-- well, mostly unfortunately for her-- I've never ridden a bus in Detroit. I really know nothing about Detroit.
不幸的是对我们俩来说——好吧，主要是对她来说——我从来没在底特律坐过公交车。我真的对底特律一无所知。
OK, so let's look at the map and just see when we're supposed to do our next thing.
好了，让我们看看地图，看看我们接下来要做什么。
OK, we will arrive to Outer Drive. Then we have to change and take another bus, bus number 125.
好的，我们到达外环路。然后我们必须换乘，搭乘另一辆公交车，125路。
So wait, we get off here and then we walk to here? Is that what that means?
所以等等，我们要在这儿下车，然后走到这里？那是那个意思吗？
No, no, no. We don't walk. This is the bus.
不，不，不。我们不用走。这就是公交车。
We're heading to southwest Detroit, to a neighborhood called Lincoln Park, to an apartment complex called Indian Village Apartments as just practice reaching a destination. We ride the number 19 bus for over half an hour.
我们要前往底特律西南部，一个叫林肯公园的街区，去一个叫“印度村公寓”的公寓区，练习到达目的地。我们乘坐19路公交车超过半小时。
We have to get off here?
我们要在这里下车吗？
DRIVER: Yeah, this is the last stop.
司机：是的，这是最后一站。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
We're supposed to transfer to another bus, but it's not so clear where we're supposed to do that. This is a moment that sometimes trips up other refugees, the transfer points, because they're afraid to approach strangers and ask for help. M does not pause. She sees two young guys sitting on a railing at a convenience store in front of a shiny black Mustang, and strides purposefully up to them. She's not very tall, 40-ish, wears squarish glasses and a hijab, a scarf covering her head.
我们应该换乘另一辆公交车，但不清楚我们在哪里换乘。这是一个有时会让其他难民绊倒的时刻，因为他们害怕接近陌生人并寻求帮助。M没有停顿。她看到两个年轻人坐在便利店的栏杆上，面前停着一辆闪亮的黑色野马，她有目的地大步朝他们走去。她不太高，40多岁，戴着方形眼镜，穿着希贾布，头巾遮住头。
Excuse me. I'm going to this area, Indian Village Apartments. So I have to get bus number 125.
打扰一下。我要去这个地区，印度村公寓。所以我必须搭乘125路公交车。
125?
125路？
Yeah, where should I go?
是的，我该去哪里？
Right here.
就在这儿。
Shall I wait here?
我该在这里等吗？
Yeah. If you want to get the bus, but if you want a ride, we can take you.
是的。如果你想搭公交车，但如果你想搭便车，我们可以载你。
He and his friend smile at her. It's a smile that says they're flirting with her, but that also says that they know this is not going to work with this devout Muslim lady standing in front of them. They know that they're going through the motions of hitting on her, because, well, that's just what you do, I guess.
他和他的朋友对着她笑。那笑容说明他们在跟她调情，但也说明他们知道站在他们面前的这位虔诚的穆斯林女士不会理会他们。他们知道他们只是在做做样子想搭讪，因为，嗯，我想这就是你们会做的。
No, thank you so much. I have to wait for the bus.
不，太谢谢了。我得等公交车。
No problem. No problem.
没问题。没问题。
Thank you so much. So it means I have to wait here, yeah?
非常感谢。所以这意味着我得在这里等，是吗？
Yeah, let me see if it's the right stop. Yeah, I think you got to wait right here.
是的，让我看看这是不是正确的站台。是的，我想你得就在这里等。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
M, maybe you can tell, is this super capable person who seems to have no problem in any situation I see her in, finding out what she needs to know and making things happen. In other words, figuring out how to ride a bus is child's play to her. She's a college grad with a bachelor's in business administration. Back home in Kabul, did project management for an international organization, humanitarian projects.
M，也许你们看出来了，是一个非常有能力的人，在我看到的任何情况下，她似乎都没有问题，能找出她需要知道的信息并解决问题。换句话说，弄清楚怎么坐公交车对她来说是小菜一碟。她拥有商科管理学士学位。在喀布尔老家时，曾为一家国际组织做项目管理，负责过人道主义项目。
I was responsible, for example, to make need assessments and then to check every stage of that project with the implementing part.
例如，我负责进行需求评估，然后与实施方核查该项目的每个阶段。
It's not unusual of course, but this immigrant who's used to a job in her own country managing things and doing PowerPoint presentations and looking at Excel spreadsheets is hoping here in America, that she'll get work as a seamstress if she she's lucky. She got her papers to work legally a month ago, and looking for work so far has landed nothing.
当然这并不罕见，但这位习惯了在本国管理事务、做PPT汇报和查看Excel表格的移民，在这里希望运气好的话能找份裁缝的工作。她一个月前拿到了合法工作许可，但到目前为止寻找工作一无所获。
OK, these two cards? This one's always first.
好吧，这两张卡？这张总是第一张。
The driver on the second just shows M how to use the transfer.
第二辆车的司机给M展示了如何使用换乘卡。
Slide through here. This one comes behind it and slide this through here. This is only worth $1.50.
从这里划过去。这张跟在后面，把这张从这里划过去。这只值1.5美元。
On the second bus, we're hoping to get off at the corner of Ford and Brest. The driver tells M that he's just filling in, so he can't help us. He doesn't know the stops. There's an automated system that calls out the stops as the bus approaches each one. It's pretty quiet.
在第二辆公交车上，我们希望能在那福特和布雷斯特的拐角下车。司机告诉M他只是代班，所以他帮不了我们。他不知道站台。有一个自动系统会在公交车接近每个站台时喊出站名。声音很小。
Ford and Brest.
福特和布雷斯特。
I think next stop.
我想是下一站。
You heard it?
你听到了吗？
No, I didn't.
不，我没听到。
He just said Ford and Brest.
他刚才说了福特和布雷斯特。
It was too loud. It was not too loud.
声音太大了。不是太大。
We wait for the bus to pull over. The automated system names other streets, Oakdale, Wesley, Birrell. And suddenly I realize--
我们等着公交车靠边。自动系统报了其他街道名，奥克代尔，卫斯理，比雷尔。突然我意识到——
We need to ring it. We need to ring it to make him stop, don't we?
我们需要按铃。我们需要按铃让他停下，对吧？
Sorry?
对不起？
We need to pull the thing to make him stop.
我们需要拉那个绳子让他停下来。
I don't know.
我不知道。
No, she doesn't know. Because in Kabul, that's not how you get the guy to stop the bus. That's why she has an American with her. I pull the cord.
不，她不知道。因为在喀布尔，那不是让司机停下公交车的方式。这就是为什么她身边有个美国人。我拉了绳子。
You know, she doesn't even know the English word for "cord" yet. She knows rope, sure but cord? That's a more subtle one. She hasn't heard that one yet. A guy in a trucker hat hears us talking about how we're looking for Ford and Brest.
你们知道，她甚至还不知道“绳子”这个英语单词。她知道“rope”（粗绳），当然知道，但“cord”（细绳）？那是一个更微妙的词。她还没听过这个词。一个戴着卡车司机帽的男人听到我们谈论怎么寻找福特和布雷斯特。
We want Ford and Brest.
我们要去福特和布雷斯特。
It's like six blocks that way.
往那边走六个街区就到了。
We passed it?
我们错过了吗？
Yeah, it's six blocks that way.
是的，往那边走六个街区。
We climb off the bus.
我们下了公交车。
OK, so here's what we learned.
好吧，这就是我们学到的。
Yeah, we are lost.
是的，我们迷路了。
No.
不。
By "no" of course, what I mean is "yes."
当我说“不”时，当然是指“是的”。
We missed our stop?
我们错过了站台？
We missed our stop.
我们错过了站台。
So what should we do now?
那我们现在该怎么办？
We walk back six blocks.
我们往回走六个街区。
OK.
好的。
Like I said, for somebody who lived through Taliban rule, whose previous job was humanitarian relief in the middle of a war, this is still not much of a challenge. Because learning to do concrete tasks, like using a bus transfer, that is not the hard part of turning yourself from an Afghan into an American.
就像我说的，对于一个经历过塔利班统治，此前在战争中心从事人道主义救援工作的人来说，这仍然算不上什么挑战。因为学习做具体任务，比如使用公交换乘，那不是从阿富汗人转变为美国人最困难的部分。
The hard part is that M is here alone. She came here for a conference a year ago. But while she was here, word got to her that certain people back home did not like what she was doing, working and traveling with foreigners. And if she came back, she and her family could be killed. That's, by the way, why I'm not saying her name.
最困难的是M是一个人在这里。她一年前来这里参加会议。但当她在这里时，传来消息说国内某些人不喜欢她做的事，即与外国人一起工作和旅行。如果她回去，她和她的家人可能会被杀害。顺便说一句，这就是为什么我不说她的名字。
So she's been apart from her children and her husband for over a year. The youngest don't even know where. They think she's in Afghanistan, because it would be dangerous if they would blab to people that she's in America.
所以她和她的孩子及丈夫已经分开了超过一年。最小的孩子甚至不知道她在哪儿。他们以为她在阿富汗，因为如果他们到处宣扬她在美洲，那会很危险。
The oldest are teenagers. The littlest is now just three. The last time she saw him, he was two. And he doesn't recognize her. He has no idea who she is when she talks to him on Skype. And the others?
最大的已经是青少年了。最小的现在只有三岁。她最后一次见到他时，他两岁。他不认识她了。当她在Skype上跟他说话时，他根本不知道她是哪位。那其他的呢？
Yeah, of course, they are asking me when are you coming back? So I just tell them, I don't know when. For me, it's very difficult because I have never been away from my children. And I was very active with work. I was a mom for my children. But here, I'm kind of idle, you know? Staying at home and doing nothing.
是的，当然，他们问我什么时候回去？我只是告诉他们，我不知道什么时候。对我来说，这非常困难，因为我从来没有离开过我的孩子。而且我工作非常积极。我是一个称职的母亲。但在这里，我处于一种游手好闲的状态，你知道吗？待在家里什么也不做。
Oh right, of course. You were busy every second before.
噢，当然。你之前每一秒都在忙碌。
But I hope that I will find a job soon.
但我希望我很快能找到工作。
It can take years to get asylum in the United States. The systems been especially backed up recently, because of the flood of children coming in from Latin America. M used to have control of her life. And now the most important thing to her in the world, getting to bring her family here, is on a time she cannot predict or control, and really may take four or five years.
在美国获得庇护可能需要几年时间。由于最近拉美儿童涌入，系统最近特别拥挤。M过去掌控着她的生活。而现在她世界上最重要的事情——能把家人带到这里——处于一个她无法预测或控制的时间线上，实际上可能需要四到五年。
The three-year-old could be eight. He's not doing well as it is. He's acting up. He's a handful for his dad. But today, the sun's shining. It's unseasonably warm. We finish walking the few blocks back to where we're supposed to be.
那个三岁的孩子可能就变成八岁了。他现在状况并不好。他很调皮。这对她爸爸来说很头疼。但今天，阳光灿烂。天气异常温暖。我们走回了我们应该到达的那几个街区。
This is our final destination. These are the Indian Village Apartments.
这是我们的最终目的地。这些就是印度村公寓。
This is our final destination. You said that just like it says on the little computer map. "You've arrived. You've arrived at your final destination."
这是我们的最终目的地。你说的就像那个小电脑地图上说的一样。“你已到达。你已到达你的最终目的地。”
You've arrived. Go down that road and your destination is on the left. So this is left, so it totally matches what we see on the map.
你已到达。沿着那条路走，目的地就在左边。所以这是左边，它完全符合我们在地图上看到的。
The tiniest of tiny victories. And since we first ran this story a year ago, she's had some more. She has a job, a place to live. She does not ride the bus anymore. She drives. One more step to becoming a real American.
微小的胜利。自我们一年前首次播出这个故事以来，她又取得了一些胜利。她有了一份工作，一个住所。她不再坐公交车了。她开车。成为一个真正美国人的又一步。
Coming up, shy man makes himself unshy without the aid of powdermilk biscuits, because you cannot get powdermilk biscuits in prison, and of course also they don't exist. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，害羞的男人在没有“奶粉饼干”的帮助下让自己变得不再害羞，因为你在监狱里买不到奶粉饼干，而且当然，它们也不存在。那是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show for the new year, as people make resolutions, we have a show that we first ran a year ago about transformers-- people willing themselves to change from one kind of person to another, trying to alter something fundamental about themselves. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Afterburner.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，给你们带来关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的新年节目，随着人们做出决定，我们要播放一个我们一年前首次播出的节目，关于变形金刚们——那些愿意让自己从一种人变成另一种人，试图改变自身本质的人。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，加力燃烧室。
So there are things I think lots of us think we might fix about ourselves. You know, like, someday, when we get around to it. And then for some of us, that day arrives, and we try to rise to the occasion. Keith O'Brien met a guy like that.
所以有很多事情我想我们很多人都认为我们应该修正一下。你知道，比如，有一天，等我们有时间的时候。然后对我们中的一些人来说，那一天到了，我们尝试迎接挑战。基思·奥布莱恩遇到过这样一个人。
Richard Pierce caught my attention the moment I met him. Rich is a prisoner of the Northern New Hampshire Correctional Facility, way up by the Canadian border, the North Country, people call it. He's unusually open, way more than most prisoners. There's a good chance he's going to be released next year. And he talks frankly about how much that scares him. But he's trying to prepare himself for that moment by joining a club called Toastmasters.
理查德·皮尔斯在我见到他的那一刻就引起了我的注意。里奇是北新罕布什尔惩教所的一名囚犯，就在加拿大边境附近，人们称之为北方地区。他异常开放，比大多数囚犯都要开朗。他很有可能明年就会获释。他坦率地谈到那让他感到多么害怕。但他正在尝试通过加入一个叫“演讲会”的俱乐部来为那一刻做准备。
At Toastmasters, people give speeches. Here in the prison, it's supposed to help inmates learn how to speak when they're in front of the parole board or in a job interview, say. And he needs to practice, because for years in prison, Rich said nothing to no one. He worked out alone, walked the yard alone, ate in the chow hall alone. Even for prison, Rich was weirdly quiet, no conversation, no give and take. He was a ghost in a green uniform.
在演讲会上，人们发表演讲。在这里，在监狱里，它旨在帮助囚犯学习如何在假释委员会面前或在求职面试中表达自己。他需要练习，因为在监狱里很多年了，里奇对任何人什么都没说。他独自锻炼，独自在操场上散步，独自在食堂吃饭。即使在监狱里，里奇也安静得奇怪，没有对话，没有互动。他是穿着绿色制服的鬼魂。
Because that's a good way to do time. And before you know it, the calendar is going by. And before you know it, it's almost time to go. And you realize that you don't really know how to talk to people anymore. And that's kind of a scary thing.
因为那是熬日子的好方法。还没等你知道，日历就翻过去了。还没等你知道，快要到时间离开了。你意识到你真的不再知道怎么和人说话了。那是一件有点可怕的事情。
What do you mean? What have you realized about that?
你是什么意思？你意识到那一点了吗？
Well, it's really freaking me out just talking to you.
嗯，跟你说话真的把我吓坏了。
You're doing a great job.
你做得很好。
And that's not normal, though. I mean, you want to be more comfortable with people. And that's my goal for the next year, is to get away from how I used to be. That's what led me to prison in the first place, not dealing with normal situations and holding back from people, not reaching out for help when you need it. And that's one of the things I need to change. It's not fun to be alone all the time. So I have to change that.
但那不正常，不是吗？我是说，你想和人们相处得更舒服。这就是我明年的目标，摆脱我过去的样子。那正是导致我入狱的原因，不去处理正常的情况，避开人们，在需要帮助时不去寻求帮助。那是我需要改变的事情之一。一直孤单一点都不好玩。所以我必须改变这一点。
Rich is 52 years old, a big guy, thick and muscular, with a long history of arsons. He's been locked up for 28 of the past 30 years, actually. But before a recent Toastmasters speech, this prison lifer, he looked like he could barely breathe.
里奇52岁了，一个大块头，肌肉发达，有着长期的纵火史。事实上，在过去的30年里他被关了28年。但在最近的一次演讲会演讲之前，这个终身监禁的囚犯看起来几乎连气都喘不过来。
How are you doing, Rich?
你好吗，里奇？
I'm a little freaking out right now. Do I look OK?
我现在有点吓坏了。我看起来还好吗？
You look great. Freaking out how?
你看上去棒极了。怎么吓坏了？
I'm very anxious. My heart's beating out of my chest. I'm very nervous.
我很焦虑。我的心快跳出胸口了。我很紧张。
I'm taking a lot of deep breaths. Everything will be fine. I'm nervous, but everything will be fine. I've been preparing for this for a couple of weeks.
我正在深呼吸。一切都会好的。我很紧张，但一切都会好的。我已经为这一刻准备了几个星期。
Toastmasters is part of Rich's master plan. It's all about re-engaging with people, with the world. He feels like if he can stand up in front of people and talk, he'll be OK in normal conversation. He'll be OK everywhere.
演讲会是里奇总体计划的一部分。这一切都是关于重新与人接触，与世界接触。他觉得如果他能站在人们面前说话，他在正常的谈话中就会没问题。他在任何地方都会没问题。
What do you think of that?
你觉得怎么样？
I think it's a great plan.
我觉得这是一个很棒的计划。
Really?
真的吗？
I do.
我是这么认为。
Wow, OK. And you're a real person and you think?
哇，好吧。你是个真实的人，你是这么想的？
I'm a real person.
我是个真实的人。
Well, that's good then.
好吧，那很好。
I'm a real person.
我是个真实的人。
The way Rich isolated himself in prison, he wasn't so different before he was locked up. When I ask why, he explains his mom drank, and she'd hit him, belittle him in front of his friends.
里奇在监狱里孤立自己的方式，在他入狱前也没什么不同。当我问为什么时，他解释说他妈妈喝酒，而且会打他，在他的朋友面前贬低他。
She would say, "What the hell do they want to go out with you for? You ain't got friends. They don't want you there. They're just saying they're your friends. You're an idiot. You're stupid. You're this. You're that."
她会说：“他们为什么要跟你出去？你根本没朋友。他们不想让你去那里。他们只是随口说说是你朋友。你是白痴。你很蠢。你是这个，你是那个。”
And before I know it, I'm like, "Yeah, why do they want to hang out with me?" And especially girls would come over to the house, "Hey, is Richard home?"
还没等我知道，我心想：“是的，他们为什么想跟我出去？”特别是有女孩来家里，“里奇在家吗？”
My mom would say, and very loudly so they could hear, "What the hell is she doing here? She doesn't want to go out with you. Look at her. She's cute. She's ain't got nothing to do with you. You're an idiot. What makes you think that she wants to go out with you? She's just trying to trick you somehow." And before I know it, I push them away because I'm not sure what they're up to.
我妈妈会说，而且声音很大让他们能听见，“她来这儿干什么？她才不想跟你出去呢。看看她。她很可爱。她才不会跟你这种人有关系呢。你是个白痴。你凭什么认为她想跟你出去？她只是想骗你什么。”还没等我知道，我就把她们推开了，因为我不确定她们到底在搞什么名堂。
Totally isolated, Rich started setting things on fire, abandoned cars, abandoned houses. No one ever got hurt. He says he just had to do it.
彻底孤立，里奇开始纵火，废弃的汽车，废弃的房屋。从没有人受过伤。他说他只是不得不这么做。
I'm trying to put my finger on it. I can't. Well, when you're told bad things so many times, over, and over, and over, and you're getting hit, and you're getting beat, and you can't get out of the house, you can't go nowhere-- when you finally get out, it's such a release just to throw things on the fire and watch it get bigger, and bigger, and bigger, until it consumes everything.
我正试着找出原因。我找不到。嗯，当你被告知坏事情这么多次，一次又一次，一次又一次，而你被打，被揍，不能离开家，哪儿也去不了——当你终于出来时，把东西扔进火里看着它变大，变大，再变大，直到它吞噬一切，这是一种释放。
And it felt like what it was consuming, it was consuming everything inside me so I didn't have to deal with it anymore. And the bigger they were, the more things it consumed out of me. Because when I walked away, even though I smelt like smoke, I felt so much better. I was ready to take on anything life had for me after that. Whereas the day before that, I couldn't take another thing. I couldn't. I just couldn't bear another thing.
感觉它在吞噬的东西，它吞噬了我内心的一切，所以我不需要再去处理它了。火越大，它吞噬掉我身上东西就越多。因为当我走开时，虽然我身上有烟味，但我感觉好多了。那之后我准备好迎接生活给我的任何东西了。而在那之前的一天，我再也受不了任何东西了。我受不了。我实在无法再承受任何东西了。
He burned up a bulldozer and got arrested. He burned down a vacant restaurant and got arrested again. But his big crime happened on July 17th, 2000. He'd been released from prison just 45 days earlier. Rich burned down a restaurant in a big condominium building near a ski resort. He was sentenced to up to 60 years in prison.
他烧了一辆推土机而被捕。他烧了一家空餐馆又被捕。但他最大的罪行发生在2000年7月17日。他刚从监狱释放才45天。里奇烧毁了一家靠近滑雪胜地的公寓大楼里的餐馆。他被判入狱长达60年。
He earned parole in 2010 on one of his two arson charges. And he knew he'd come up for parole on the other arson charge five years later. That's when Rich decided he couldn't be alone anymore.
他在2010年因其中一项纵火指控获得了假释。他知道五年后他会因为另一项纵火指控面临假释听证。那是里奇决定他不能再独自一人的时候。
5 years, that's right around the corner. I got 10 years in already.
5年，就在眼前了。我已经进去了10年。
[BLEEP]
[哔——]
I might get out after all. It's only one more president away. [BLEEP] What am I going to do? Where am I going to live? Where am I going to work?
我毕竟可能会出去。只剩一位总统任期了。[哔——]我该做什么？我该住在哪里？我该在哪儿工作？
I'm going to be real pretty soon. I can't just not talk to people anymore. I can't be isolated anymore. And that's when the realization hit me that I need to start practicing.
很快就会成真了。我不能再不跟人说话了。我不能再被孤立了。也就是那时，我意识到我需要开始练习。
He joined the prison chess club. He began eating with others, forced himself to do it. And the prison psychologists, the mental gals, Rich calls them, gave him a challenge. Speak to three people, three, in a single day. One morning, Rich woke up, got dressed, and approached a total stranger on the cell block thinking, "OK, I'll try."
他加入了监狱象棋俱乐部。他开始和别人一起吃饭，强迫自己这么做。监狱心理学家，“精神姑娘们”，里奇这样称呼她们，给了他一个挑战。每天，每天，和三个人说话。一天早上，里奇醒来，穿好衣服，走向牢房区的一个陌生人，心里想着，“好的，我试试。”
I said, "Hey, mind if I sit down  for a minute?" And he looked up at me really quizzical. He says, "I've been on this pod six months, and that's the first time I ever heard you speak." That's like a slap in the face. It's a realization of how isolated you really are. I mean, it's a pod with 70 people. It's like a fishbowl. You're all intermingled, and how can you go that long without even hearing your voice?
我说，“嘿，介意我坐一会儿吗？”他非常困惑地抬头看着我。他说，“我在这儿待了六个月了，这是我第一次听你说话。”那就像一记耳光。意识到你到底有多孤立。我是说，这是一个有70人的牢房区。就像个鱼缸。你们全都混在一起，怎么可能这么久连你的声音都没听到？
And how long did you sit there talking with him for?
你和他在那里谈了多久？
Oh, about 10 or 15 minutes. You know, where are you from, what do you do for work? How long you are here? You know, things like that. I'm from Littleton. Where's that at? Oh, it's right around here. Oh, is it near woods? I like the pond or this or that.
哦，大概10或15分钟。你知道的，你从哪儿来，你做什么工作？你在这儿多久了？你知道，诸如此类的事情。我来自利特尔顿。那在哪儿啊？哦，就在这附近。哦，是靠近树林吗？我喜欢池塘或者这个或那个。
Yeah, yeah, there's these trails, and this lake, and some other small talk. And as I'm talking, I realize that this isn't nowhere near as difficult as I thought it would be and maybe the mental gals are onto something, because if I can do this here, people don't know they're experiments that I'm practicing for freedom. They just think it's a normal conversation, but to me it's a lot more. It's like practice.
是啊，是啊，有这些小径，这个湖，还有一些闲聊。在谈话时，我意识到这根本没有我想象的那么难，也许精神姑娘们是对的，因为如果我能在这里做到这一点，人们不知道他们是我为自由准备的实验对象。他们只是觉得这是一次正常的谈话，但对我来说意义远不止于此。就像练习一样。
Rich was on the hunt now for two more people.
里奇现在正在寻找另外两个人。
I got to find a communication victim. I looked over and seen somebody by himself. Ah-hah. He's going to be my experiment.
我得找个沟通受害者。我往那边看，看到一个人独自在那儿。啊哈。他将成为我的实验品。
He found victim number two working out. They talked about push ups and pull ups, guy stuff. He cornered victim number three on the basketball court, ended up playing hoops for a while. And when the day was over, Rich figured he'd spoken for 45 minutes, a Richard Pierce record.
他发现了二号受害者在锻炼。他们聊了俯卧撑和引体向上，男人之间的东西。他在篮球场把三号受害者逼到角落，最后打了一会儿篮球。当这一天结束时，里奇计算他谈了45分钟，理查德·皮尔斯记录。
The mental gals, the chess, these conversations, they were working. But none of them prepared Rich for Toastmasters, the key, he thought, to real change. Because of course, in Toastmasters, he couldn't just sit there. He had to talk.
精神姑娘们，下棋，这些对话，它们起作用了。但没有哪一个为里奇准备好演讲会，他认为那是真正改变的关键。因为当然，在演讲会中，他不能只是坐在那里。他必须说话。
They said, "You want to do an icebreaker speech?" And I'm like, "Icebreaker speech? What are you talking about, icebreaker speech?" That's how freaked out I was, just right then and there.
他们说，“你想做一个破冰演讲吗？”我说，“破冰演讲？你们在说什么，破冰演讲？”这就是我当时吓坏的程度，就在那个当下。
Your hands were trembling.
你的手在颤抖。
Yes, the anxiety came that quick. I'm like, "OK, if I think I'm just going to get up there, I'm going to fall over and die. I'm going to have a heart attack. I'm going to fall over and die. That's what's going to happen."
是的，焦虑来得那么快。我心想，“好的，如果我想我只是会站在那儿，我会倒下死掉的。我会心脏病发作的。我会倒下死掉的。这就是将要发生的事。”
You really thought you would die.
你真的以为你会死。
Well, that was my first thought. Get up, your heart's going to burst and they're going to die.
嗯，那是我的第一个念头。站起来，你的心会爆裂，他们会死。
OK, on to the speaking portion of our program tonight.
好了，进入今晚节目的演讲环节。
Rich, of course, didn't die that night, or the night after that. He's been coming to Toastmasters for a few months now, slowly building up the courage to speak and the skills to do it. I was at the meeting the night he got up and gave a speech for the second time. He was introduced by another prisoner.
里奇，当然，那天晚上没死，或者第二天晚上也没死。他来演讲会已经几个月了，慢慢建立了说话的勇气和技巧。我参加了那个他站起来第二次发表演讲的会议。他是被另一名囚犯介绍出来的。
Speaker number one, title to his speech is "Yet Another Reason Why It's not a Good Idea to Dress Up as a Police Officer." Mr. Pierce, welcome.
演讲者一号，他的演讲题目是“为什么打扮成警察不是个好主意”。皮尔斯先生，欢迎。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Rich's assignment tonight was get to the point. Give a well-structured speech in five to seven minutes. Rich chose to talk about the time 30 years ago he decided to dress up as a cop for Halloween.
里奇今晚的任务是说到点子上。在五到七分钟内进行结构合理的演讲。里奇选择了谈论30年前他决定在万圣节打扮成警察的时刻。
And I worked on myself in the mirror and I was quite impressed. I was confident I would scare the wits out of my friends and my coworkers. What could go wrong?
我在镜子里研究了自己，印象非常深刻。我很自信我会吓坏我的朋友和同事。会有什么问题呢？
Watching him talk, I just didn't want him to fail. Here was Rich, standing in front of a dozen people, palms placed flat on the podium.
看着他说话，我只是不想让他失败。这就是里奇，站在十几个人面前，手掌平放在讲台上。
Then she says, hey, I've got a great idea, her face brightens. How about if you was to stick your-- point your--
然后她说，嘿，我有个好主意，她的脸亮了起来。要是你把你的……指着你的……
He's lost his place, snapping his fingers, trying to remember the words.
他忘记了他的位置，弹着手指，试着回想那些词。
Point your cap guns at me? And I'll raise my hands and I'll give you the cash out of the drawer. Wouldn't that be a gas, she says?
用玩具枪指着我？我举起手，把抽屉里的现金给你。那不是很有趣吗，她说？
He recovered. Then his story wandered a little, but he got a lot of laughs. He connected with the room, a real victory.
他恢复了过来。然后他的故事有点偏离了方向，但他赢得了许多笑声。他与房间连接起来了，真正的胜利。
The end.
结束。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
After the speech, Rich was really hard on himself. In his self-evaluation, he wrote down three words-- "Horrible, needs practice." But his peers were more forgiving. "Excellent job," they wrote. "Great progress, very good eye contact, very welcoming." They called him "Winning and funny." One inmate said they should have storytelling every Saturday night on the cell block with Mr. Pierce. Another told Rich he had nothing to fear. He was just as good as anyone else.
演讲后，里奇对自己真的很苛刻。在自我评估中，他写了三个词——“糟糕，需要练习。”但他的同伴更宽容。“出色的工作，”他们写道。“巨大的进步，非常好的眼神接触，非常受欢迎。”他们称他“迷人且有趣。”一名囚犯说他们应该每个周六晚上在牢房区和皮尔斯先生进行讲故事活动。另一名告诉里奇他没什么可害怕的。他和任何人一样好。
Rich had been nervous, trembling even. And no one noticed.
里奇一直很紧张，甚至在颤抖。没人注意到。
So my insides don't match up my outsides. But that's probably true for many people, don't you think?
所以我的内心和我的外表不匹配。但这对于许多人来说可能是真的，你不觉得吗？
I do, actually. In that way, it's very, very normal.
其实我这么觉得。从那种意义上说，这非常，非常正常。
Yeah, so that's comforting, that I can always portray myself as confident when I'm not, until it comes naturally, anyway.
是啊，所以这很安慰，我总能把自己描绘成自信的样子，虽然我不是，直到它自然而然地发生，无论如何。
I got news for you, Rich. A lot of people on the outside, a lot of quote unquote "real people," they do that all the time.
我有个消息告诉你，里奇。外面的许多人，许多所谓的“真实的人”，他们一直都在这样做。
Really?
真的吗？
Absolutely.
绝对。
How do you know? Are you sure?
你怎么知道？你确定吗？
I'm quite sure. People put on airs all the time. People often will act like they're more confident than they really are. It's normal.
我很确定。人们一直都在摆架子。人们经常会表现得比他们真正的情况更自信。这很正常。
Yeah, I suppose so. I suppose so. Well, that's comforting to know, that I'm not like a total washout.
是啊，我想也是。我想也是。嗯，知道这点很安慰，我不是一个彻底的失败者。
No, he's not. He doesn't accept it, but it's true. He's way more normal than he thinks.
不，他不是。他不接受这一点，但这是真的。他比他自己认为的要正常得多。
Keith O'Brien in New Hampshire. Since we first ran this story a year ago, Rich got out on parole and is now married and living in Colorado. His wife first heard him on our radio show and started writing to him. They wrote to each other. One thing led to another.
在新罕布什尔的基思·奥布莱恩。自我们一年前首次播出这个故事以来，里奇通过假释获释，现在已经结婚并住在科罗拉多。他的妻子第一次在我们的广播节目中听到了他，并开始写信给他。他们互相写信。事情就这样发展开了。
Act Four, Trailbreaker. So it's not just that deciding to change your life can be completely momentous. Telling people about the decision can be a big deal too. Sean Cole has an example.
第四幕，开拓者。所以这不仅仅是决定改变你的生活可能是完全重大的。告诉人们这个决定也可能是一件大事。肖恩·科尔有一个例子。
The beginning of this story is as ordinary as you can imagine. A kid comes out to his family during Thanksgiving break from college. The kid was Andy Greer. It was 1989. He said it like this.
这个故事的开头像你想象的那么普通。一个孩子在大学感恩节假期期间向他的家人出柜。那个孩子是安迪·格里尔。那是1989年。他这么说。
Mom and Dad, I'm sure it won't surprise you, but I'm gay and I'm really happy about it.
妈妈和爸爸，我相信这不会让你们惊讶，但我是同性恋，而且我对此感到非常快乐。
His mom, indeed, was not surprised. His father, he remembers, was very surprised, which was kind of amazing given all of the years Andy spent at musical theater camp.
他妈妈，确实没感到惊讶。他的父亲，他记得，非常惊讶，这真是太神奇了，考虑到安迪在音乐剧夏令营度过的所有岁月。
Well, of course he thought about it.
好吧，他当然想过。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I later discovered a book in my house called Growing Up Straight that had all these rules underlined about how to bring up your child heterosexual.
我后来在我家发现了一本叫《直着长大》的书，上面画满了关于如何让你的孩子异性恋的规则。
Wait. How to bring up your child as a straight child?
等等。如何让你的孩子成长为直的孩子？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was things like take them camping at Civil War sites and collect arrowheads. And I'm like, oh I remember doing that.
是啊，是啊，是啊。这是诸如带他们去内战遗址露营和收集箭头之类的事情。我就想，哦我记得做过那个。
That seems very particular.
那看起来非常具体。
It was very particular. Yeah. Play mumblety-peg was one of them.
它非常具体。是啊。玩“木桩游戏”是其中之一。
What is mumblety-peg?
什么是木桩游戏？
It's where you throw a knife at a stump.
那是你向树桩扔刀子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which we did that, yeah. It was fun.
我们做了那个，是啊。这很有趣。
How is that supposed to straighten you?
那怎么会被认为能让你变直？
It doesn't seem like even the wrist movement would be helpful.
看起来甚至手腕的运动都不会有帮助。
Andy says that night he announced to the mumblety-peg hadn't worked, his dad responded with "I have to think about this a while." And then Andy did what you do in 1989 suburban Maryland when you've just come out to your parents. He drove to the mall and wandered in and out of stores thinking about what just happened. And when he got back to the parking lot, he realized he'd locked his keys in the car. His mom's car that he'd borrowed in order to drive off in a strident blaze of glory.
安迪说那天晚上他宣布木桩游戏没起作用，他爸爸回答说“我得好好想想这件事”。然后安迪做了你在1989年马里兰州郊区刚向父母出柜后会做的事。他开车去购物中心，在商店里徘徊，想着刚才发生的事。当他回到停车场时，他意识到他把钥匙锁在车里了。他妈妈借给他开的那辆车，为了以此作为闪耀的荣耀而开走。
Because I ran out of the house like I'd won this round. So I found a payphone. It's 1989, right? So I called my mom mortified. And I thought, "Well, now I've really screwed it up. Locking my keys in the car has proved how I I'm not a responsible adult at all. How could I even know that I'm gay?"
因为我像赢了这一轮一样跑出房子。所以我找了一个公用电话。是1989年，对吧？所以我羞愧地给我妈打了电话。我心想，“好吧，现在我真的搞砸了。把钥匙锁在车里证明了我根本不是一个负责任的成年人。我怎么可能知道我是同性恋？”
So Andy's in a snowy parking lot alone. Finally his mom drives up in the family's other car, gets out, and if this were a much shorter story, she would have simply given him the spare set of keys and driven home.
所以安迪独自在一个下雪的停车场。最后他妈妈开了家里的另一辆车过来，下了车，如果这是一个短得多的故事，她会简单地给他备用钥匙然后开车回家。
But instead she unlocks the car and then gets in the other the passenger side and sits in the car with me.
但相反，她打开车锁，然后坐进另一边的乘客位，坐在车里和我在一起。
And closes the door.
并关上门。
Closes the door.
关上门。
And you're like, "What are you doing?"
你当时像，“你在做什么？”
Well, I'm thinking, "Oh, no. Now we're going to have the talk." That I fled. [GROANING]
嗯，我心想，“哦，不。现在我们要谈谈了。”我逃避的那次。[呻吟声]
She looked not happy. I was ready for that whole thing. "I can't believe what you just did to our family." Something like that.
她看起来不高兴。我做好了面对那一整套的准备。“我不敢相信你刚刚对我们的家庭做了什么。”之类的。
And what did she say?
然后她说了什么？
She said, "About what you said earlier. I think I'm gay too."
她说，“关于你刚才说的那件事。我想我也是同性恋。”
What?
什么？
Yeah. I was really surprised.
是啊。我很惊讶。
I don't know--
我不知道——
Really, the emotion I felt was, "I am completely off the hook now." Oh, I thought. This, oh my God. This is way bigger than my story. No one's going to care about me. Like, once I really understood what she was saying--
真的，我感到的情绪是，“现在我完全解脱了。”哦，我心想。这，天啊。这比我的故事大多了。没人会关心我。就像，一旦我真的理解了她所说的——
You're like, I have nothing to worry about.
你心想，我没什么可担心的了。
I have nothing to worry about.
我没什么可担心的。
That was the first thing he thought. The next thing was more like, what the hell's going on here? After all, Andy was a 19-year-old college sophomore at this point. He still thought that once you reached middle age, you didn't change anymore. Like his parents were these two paintings hanging in the house, paintings that cooked him dinner when he came home.
这是他想到的第一件事。下一件事更像是，这到底发生了什么？毕竟，安迪当时是一个19岁的大学二年级学生。他依然认为一旦你到了中年，你就不再改变了。就像他的父母是挂在房子里的两幅画，当他回家时给做饭的画。
I hadn't considered you could actually propose a completely new life, and that you'd been thinking about it all along. All along? My whole life she'd been waiting for this?
我没考虑过你真的可以提出一个全新的生活，而且你一直都在思考它。一直以来？我的一生她都在等待这个？
Oh, I did forget to say, after she said "I think I'm gay too," long pause, and then she says, "Don't tell your father."
哦，我确实忘了说，在她说了“我想我也是同性恋”之后，长时间的停顿，然后她说，“别告诉你爸爸。”
So you have to keep this secret from your dad.
所以你得瞒着你爸保守这个秘密。
Right.
对。
Which is the hugest secret.
这是一个巨大的秘密。
I just couldn't bear it. It was such a huge secret.
我真的受不了了。这是一个巨大的秘密。
I'm trying to think of a bigger secret you could keep from your dad.
我正试着想一个你瞒着你爸能保守的更大的秘密。
Murder.
谋杀。
You murdered somebody.
你谋杀了一个人。
Yeah.
是啊。
Or your mom.
或者你妈妈。
My mom murdered somebody.
我妈妈谋杀了一个人。
Your mom murdered somebody. That would be bigger.
你妈妈谋杀了一个人。那会更大。
Yeah.
是啊。
Or your mom is Spider-man.
或者你妈妈是蜘蛛侠。
Yes.
是的。
That would be bigger.
那会更大。
That's kind of how it felt, like my mom was Spider-man in some way, because to me it was also exciting that I knew her secret identity. The things were all together in my head.
这感觉有点像，就像我妈在某种程度上是蜘蛛侠，因为对我来说，知道她的秘密身份也很令人兴奋。这些东西在我的脑海里全都结合在一起。
Well, it was not Thanksgiving. It was January of 1990.
嗯，那不是感恩节。那是1990年1月。
This, of course, is Andy's mom, Sandra Greer. She remembers the story a little differently than Andy in places-- not only that it wasn't on Thanksgiving, but also that she and Andy's dad started wondering if Andy might be gay when he was four years old, hence the Growing Up Straight book. So it wasn't much of a shock.
这，当然，是安迪的妈妈，桑德拉·格里尔。她在某些地方记得这个故事和安迪有点不同——不仅不是在感恩节，而且她和安迪的爸爸在安迪四岁时就开始怀疑他可能是同性恋，因此有了那本《直着长大》的书。所以这并没有多大冲击。
And one other thing you should know about Sandra before we continue is that she's an experimental chemist. Not just by profession. That's how she thinks about everything. For instance, she told me that when Andy announced he was gay, she had already started this long, slow process of coming out herself.
而且在我们要继续之前你应该知道关于桑德拉的另一件事是她是一位实验化学家。不仅是职业。那是她思考一切的方式。例如，她告诉我，当安迪宣布他是同性恋时，她已经开始了自己漫长、缓慢的出柜过程。
And it is true that his coming out probably catalyzed my coming out. It would have happened, but it would have taken maybe a little longer. I choose the word "catalyzed" carefully. A catalyst changes the rate of things but does not change the final state of equilibrium. And so when I say his coming out was a catalyst, I mean exactly that.
确实，他的出柜可能催化了我的出柜。它会发生的，但它可能需要稍微长一点的时间。我仔细选择“催化”这个词。催化剂改变了事物速率但并没有改变最终的平衡状态。所以当我说是他的出柜是催化剂时，我指的就是那个。
You see what I have to live with?
你们看到我必须和什么一起生活了吗？
Believe it or not, Andy and his mom actually haven't talked about any of this in the quarter century since it happened. And one of Andy's burning questions has been about Sandra's state of mind in between his big reveal in the kitchen and the moment she hopped in the car with him. What was going on in her head? He figured-- in fact, he told her when we were all talking about it. He says you must have been in some emotional turmoil during that hour or so. But again, Sandra is a pragmatist and very much a mom.
信不信由你，安迪和他的妈妈实际上在过去二十五年里并没有谈论任何这些事情。安迪的其中一个迫切问题是关于桑德拉在厨房里他进行大揭密和她跳进车里陪他的那段时间里的心态。她在想什么？他心想——事实上，当我们在谈论它时他告诉她。他说你一定在那一小时左右经历了某种情感动荡。但再一次，桑德拉是一个实用主义者，而且非常是一个妈妈。
I was thinking that I needed to find a way to say this, and that this was about the only time that he and I would be alone, and that his coming out to me-- not only did it give me permission to say this, but that it might be helpful to him to know that I knew what he was going through and for him to give me some support.
我在想我需要找到一种方法来说出这件事，而且这是他和我能单独相处的唯一时间，而且他的向我出柜——不仅给了我允许来说出这件事，而且知道我了解他正在经历什么并给他提供一些支持对他可能有帮助。
But were you nervous?
但你紧张吗？
Yes, I was. Yes, I was. I mean, this was a pretty big deal. So I was nervous, and at the same time a little relieved that I could talk to him about it.
是的，我是。是的，我是。我是说，这是一个相当大的事。所以我很紧张，同时又有点解脱，我可以和他谈谈这件事。
And as they were sitting there in the car, Andy quickly realized, wait a second. This means we aren't going to be a family anymore. Not in the same way, which wasn't a relief and wasn't exciting. Plus, it's just that he figured he was the gay one in the family.
当他们坐在车里时，安迪很快意识到，等一下。这意味着我们不再是一个家庭了。不再以同样的方式，那并不让人解脱也不让人兴奋。另外，只是他认为他是家里那个同性恋。
Yeah, and then mom takes over the show.
是啊，然后妈妈接管了节目。
Oh, so you felt like she was stealing your thunder a little bit.
哦，所以你觉得她稍微抢了你的风头。
Well, yeah, yeah, yeah. And after that she did a little, because she would start to tell relatives that I was gay.
嗯，是啊，是啊，是啊。在那之后她做了一点，因为她会开始告诉亲戚我是同性恋。
And this is where the story becomes not a story about the secretly gay mother of an openly gay son, but the ingeniously clever secretly gay mother of an openly gay son. The way Andy tells it, his mom basically took to the phones like a pollster in a boiler room, spreading the word that someone they knew very well had come out of the closet.
而这就是故事变成不是一个关于 openly gay 儿子的秘密同性恋母亲的故事，而是那个巧妙机智的 openly gay 儿子的秘密同性恋母亲的故事。按照安迪的说法，他妈妈基本上像锅炉房里的民意调查员一样拿起电话，四处传播消息说他们非常了解的人已经出柜了。
Well, because of course, she was trying to figure out how people would react, her mother would react to someone being gay at all, kind of test the waters for herself. But my mom was telling all kinds of people, my great great aunt, and Aunt Dot, and all these people I didn't really know.
嗯，因为当然，她在试图弄清楚人们会有什么反应，她的妈妈会有什么反应关于有人是同性恋，有点为自己试水。但我妈在告诉各种各样的人，我的太姑母，还有多特阿姨，以及所有那些我并不真正认识的人。
Wait. And you're like, "Wait, Mom."
等等。你当时像，“等等，妈妈。”
Yeah, it was spiraling out of control. Yeah, the Coopersteins knew. Yeah.
是啊，它失去控制了。是啊，库珀斯坦一家知道了。是啊。
Who are the Coopersteins?
库珀斯坦一家是谁？
They were our next door neighbors since i was a kid. Because I didn't think about those people except at holidays. So when I went back to school, I didn't think, well, I'd better call the Coopersteins now, because they were out of my mind. And then a week later, I hear that the Coopersteins, Myrna Cooperstein has something to say about it.
他们从我小时候起就是我们的隔壁邻居。因为我除了在假期时从不考虑那些人。所以当我回到学校时，我没想，好吧，我最好现在给库珀斯坦一家打电话，因为他们不在我的脑海里。然后一周后，我听说库珀斯坦一家，米尔娜·库珀斯坦对此有话要说。
And were you mad?
你当时生气吗？
No, she needed my story more than I did. Because she needed to test these people out. And it was the perfect way to do it before she dropped her own bomb, probably a year or so later.
不，她比我更需要我的故事。因为她需要测试这些人。而且这是她在一年左右后投下自己炸弹之前测试这些人的完美方法。
Actually, it wasn't a year or so later, says Andy's mom, Sandra. She remembers this part differently too. She says she told Andy's twin brother Mike just a couple of days later, and told their father only a couple of months after that, and then moved out in the spring. Also, she says she doesn't remember calling around to anybody about Andy except for her mother and her sister. And yes, she probably told Myrna Cooperstein. But her coming out and Andy's coming out, they aren't as connected as that, she told me.
实际上，那并不是一年左右后，安迪的妈妈桑德拉说。她记得这部分也不同。她说她在几天后才告诉安迪的双胞胎兄弟迈克，几个月后才告诉他们的父亲，然后在春天搬走了。而且，她说她不记得除了她的母亲和姐妹之外还有告诉过关于安迪的任何人。而且是的，她可能告诉了米尔娜·库珀斯坦。但她的出柜和安迪的出柜，它们不像那样连接在一起，她告诉我。
I guess the way that I think they may be connected-- so you're a chemist. And in a way, it seems like telling folks around you that Andy is gay, it's like the perfect litmus test, in a way.
我猜我想它们可能连接在一起的方式——所以你是一名化学家。而且以某种方式，告诉周围的人安迪是同性恋似乎就像完美的石蕊试纸。
Ah, very good. Well done.
啊，非常好。干得好。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I don't know that I consciously thought of it that way, but it certainly gave me more information. It gave me more information for my process, which was going to come later.
我不知道我有意识地那样想过，但这肯定给了我更多的信息。它为我的过程提供了更多信息，这将在后面出现。
So what information did it?
那给了什么信息？
The sky did not fall down. Life went on as we know it. Nobody disowned anybody. Nothing really bad happened.
天没塌下来。生活正如我们所知继续着。没有人抛弃任何人。没发生什么真正糟糕的事。
You've got to wonder what it must have been like for Sandra. She was 45. She says she hadn't so much as kissed a woman yet, and here comes her 19 year old son just boldly saying the very things she's been hiding about herself, like he was speaking her secret out loud. Did she feel some kind of twinge in her gut or some chill or something?
你得想这对桑德拉来说一定是什么样。她45岁了。她说她甚至还没吻过女人，而这里是她19岁的儿子勇敢地说出了她一直隐瞒的关于自己的事情，就像他在大声说出她的秘密一样。她感到胃里有某种刺痛或寒战之类的东西吗？
I would say that he was more a role model for me.
我会说他对我来说更是一个榜样。
Oh, Mom.
哦，妈妈。
That he could show me how you could do this and live your life with integrity. He just flat out came out, and there was no hedging about it, and he didn't screw around about it. And the result was that people who loved you still loved you.
他能向我展示你是怎么做到的，并以正直的方式生活。他只是直接出柜了，没有任何敷衍，他没有在这件事上浪费时间。结果是爱你的那些人依然爱你。
Well, that's a completely different way of seeing it. Wow.
嗯，这完全是另一种看待它的方式。哇。
Yeah, I think that's the way I felt about it, that he was showing me how to do things.
是啊，我想这就是我对它的感觉，他是在展示我怎么做事。
The funny thing is that Andy, for all his role modeliness, again, he was still a kid. And he still had a thing or to learn from his mom about being open minded.
有趣的是安迪，对于他所有的role modeliness（榜样性），再一次，他依然是个孩子。而且他还有一两件事要向他妈妈学习关于开放心态。
I had gone into this situation and basically said, "I'm not who you think I am. I'm my own person, and you're going to have to deal with it." And then my mom said, "I'm not who you think I am. I'm going to be my own person."
我进入了这个情况并基本上说，“我不是你们认为的那个人。我是我自己的人，你们将不得不处理它。”然后我妈说，“我不是你们认为的那个人。我将成为我自己的人。”
I was like, "no, no, no, but you have to. You're the mom. Not fair." And then you also have to think about your parent as a human being. No, I was not ready. I was not open minded enough to consider some golden rule about how you're supposed to act at coming out stories.
我当时像，“不，不，不，但你必须。你是妈妈。不公平。”而且你还必须把你的父母当作一个人来考虑。不，我没准备好。我没有开放的心态去考虑关于出柜故事的所谓金科玉律。
Do unto others.
己所不欲，勿施于人。
Yeah.
是啊。
But he got over it. And within a year or so, Sandra was living as a fully out gay person. Of course, we all have these catalytic people in our lives. Usually, it's an older sibling or a friend, the first person we knew who got us listening to cool music for a change, or kissed somebody, or left home and moved to a new city. Or it's your parents you're fashioning yourself after somehow. How often is it that a person you created and raised is the one who leads you over a threshold?
但他克服了。一年左右，桑德拉生活作为一个完全出柜的同性恋者。当然，我们生活中都有这些催化剂般的人。通常，这是一个年长的兄弟姐妹或朋友，我们认识的第一个人，让我们开始听酷音乐，或者亲吻过某人，或者离开家搬到了一个新城市。或者它是你以某种方式塑造自己的父母。一个人你创造并养育的是引领你越过门槛的，这种情况有多频繁？
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program. Andrew Sean Greer, the guy in that story, is a novelist. His latest book, The Impossible Lives of Greta Wells.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。安德鲁·肖恩·格里尔，那个故事里的人，是一位小说家。他最新的书，《格里塔·威尔斯的不可思议生活》。
[MUSIC - "CHANGES" BY LANGHORNE SLIM AND THE LAW]
[音乐 - 《变化》 by Langhorne Slim and the Law]
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek, with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for this episode is Brian Reed. Our editor for this episode was Joel Lovell. Editorial help for this episode by Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Whitney Dangerfield, Kimberly Henderson, Seth Lind.
我们的节目今天由米奇·米克制作，与佐伊·蔡斯，肖恩·科尔，尼尔·德鲁明，斯蒂芬妮·福，查娜·乔菲-沃尔特，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔，罗宾·塞米恩，阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。本期节目的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。本期节目的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。本期节目的编辑协助来自朱莉·斯奈德。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作协助来自伊曼纽尔·佐齐。我们的职员包括埃莉斯·伯格森，惠特尼·丹格菲尔德，金伯利·亨德森，塞思·林德。
Research out help from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Richard Davis and Debra Drennan, Marty Heresniak, WBEZ's Collin Ashmead-Bobbitt, Marketplace's Stephen Cologne, and Cornell University's Bert Odom-Reed.
研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。今天特别感谢理查德·戴维斯和黛布拉·德雷南，马蒂·赫雷斯尼亚克，WBEZ的科林·阿什米德-博比特，Marketplace的斯蒂芬·科隆，和康奈尔大学的伯特·奥多姆-里德。
The podcast, Unfictional , that you heard some excerpts from at the beginning of today's program comes KCRW. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who dressed as Chicken Little for Halloween this year. And no, he was disappointed how it worked out.
播客《非虚构》，你在今天节目开始时听到的一些节选来自于KCRW。此《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他在今年万圣节打扮成“小鸡快跑”。而且不，他对结果很失望。
The sky did not fall down.
天没塌下来。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "CHANGES" BY LANGHORNE SLIM AND THE LAW]
[音乐 - 《变化》 by Langhorne Slim and the Law]